♪ ♪
>> Greg: JOHN SAID I AM
LEAVING TO BE WITH YOKO AND PAUL
SAID, IS THIS SOME KIND OF
JOKE-O?
IN A BBC INTERVIEW THAT WILL BE
BROADCAST NEXT MONTH THAT WE
WILL BE LISTENING TO, PAUL
McCARTNEY PUSHES BACK ON THE
NARRATIVE THAT HE WAS THE REASON
THAT THE BEATLES BROKE UP MORE
THAN 50 YEARS AGO.
THAT'S A LONG TIME.
SAYING THE REAL REASON WAS THAT
JOHN WAS MAKING A NEW LIFE WITH
YOKO AND ADDED JOHN WALKED INTO
A ROOM ONE DAY AND SAID I'M
LEAVING THE BEATLES.
IS THAT INSTIGATING THE SPLIT OR
NOT?
MAYBE THAT'S HOW THEY WROTE
"HELLO GOODBYE AIRED" HE SAYS HE
HAS NO HARD FEELINGS AGAINST
YOKO AND THAT THEY WERE A GREAT
COUPLE BUT HE DOES HOPE TO
OUTLIVE RINGO.
THAT'S A LIE.
LET'S NOT FORGET THAT FOLLOWING
LENIN'S DEPARTURE, THE MUSIC
TOOK A NOTICEABLE TURN.
SEEM SO FAR AWAY.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEWING ALL RIGHT.
MY THEORY, TYRUS, I BELIEVE THAT
LENNON WAS RIGHT TO GET OUT THEN
BECAUSE OF THE BEATLES HAD STUCK
AROUND AS A GROUP, THEY WOULD'VE
PUT OUT LESSER AND LESSER
QUALITY PRODUCTS AND THEY WOULD
BE RICH BUT THEY WOULD BE LIKE
U2.
--
MAYBE THEY DID PUT OUT A LOT OF
GOOD ALBUMS.
ARROWSMITH AFTER "TOYS IN THE
ATTIC."
>> I'M SORRY, BUT DID ANYONE
WAKE UP THIS MORNING GOING WE
HAVE TO FIND OUT -- NO, NO, NO,
KIDS, WE ARE NOT GOING TO SCHOOL
TODAY.
DADDY HAS TO KNOW IT WAS A
RINGO, WAS IT JOHN?
WAS IT THE MAN?
AND WE ALREADY KNOW IT'S RINGO.
RINGO DID IT.
HE WAS THE ONE GOING BACK AND
FORTH TELLING EACH GUY HE WAS
BETTER THAN HE REALLY WAS.
IT WAS LIKE MAN, PAUL, IF YOU
ARE IN CHARGE, I WOULD GET MORE
DRUM SOLOS AND THEN HE WOULD GO
TO JOHN AND BE LIKE HEY, PAUL
SAID I COULD GET MORE DRUM SOLOS
IF YOU SANG LESS.
WE KNOW HE DID IT.
IT WAS RINGO'S PUNK WHO DID IT.
HE BROKE THE TEAM UP.
>> Greg: THAT IS THE FIRST
TIME I'VE EVER HEARD ANYBODY
BLAME RINGO.
HE WAS IN A GREAT MOVIE CALLED
"CAVEMAN."
>> I HAD A BIRD NAMED TO RINGO.
I WAS A HUGE FAN GROWING UP AND
I DON'T KNOW WHY.
>> AND THEN HE RUINED.
>> I HAD A BIRD NAMED RINGO THAT
MY MOM MADE ME GIVEAWAY AND THEN
I GOT A DOG.
SPEAK OUT RINGO LET YOU DOWN.
>> Greg: DON'T APOLOGIZE FOR
BEING A BEATLES FAN.
>> NO, IT'S FUNNY BECAUSE MY
PARENTS WEREN'T INTO THE BEATLES
THAT MUCH AND I FOUND THEM AND
THERE ARE ONE OF THE GREATEST
MUSICAL HATS OF ALL TIME AND SO
I LOVE THEM BUT I SAW -- THIS
WAS NOT MY IDEA.
I SAW SOMEBODY POST EARLIER YOKO
ONO WAS TO THE BEATLES WHAT
MEGHAN MARKLE IS TO THE ROYAL
FAMILY.
THAT IS NOT MIND AND I'M NOT
SAYING THAT BUT I'M JUST
THROWING IT OUT THERE.
>> Greg: THAT IMPLIES THAT
PRINCE HARRY HAD TALENT.
YOU KNOW IT'S FUNNY?
YOU KNOW IT'S FUNNY TO ME IS
THAT WHEN I WAS GROWING UP, THE
BEATLES WITH A GOOD BAND AND THE
ROLLING STONES WAS THE SCARY
BAND AND THAT SURELY THE
ROLLING STONES WOULD BE THE ONE
THAT WOULD DISINTEGRATE.
BECAUSE THEY WERE THE BAD BOYS.
AND WHO YOU ARE.
IT'S LIKE 60 YEARS THE STONES
HAVE BEEN AROUND.
>> THEY HAD GREAT HAIR STYLE SO
WE CAN START WITH THAT.
BEYOND THAT --
McCARTNEY ON THE FALL RIGHT
THERE.
BUT I WILL SAY THIS.
AM I IN THE ONLY PERSON HERE WHO
THINKS THE BEATLES IS OVERRATED?
TAKE THIS FOR A SECOND.
>> SO MANY PEOPLE HAVE SAID
THAT.
OH, THE BEATLES ARE NOT EVEN
GOOD.
I'M GOING TO COME ON THE SHOW
AND BE ABOUT US.
I'M SO COOL.
I'M TOO COOL FOR THE BEATLES.
LET'S SEE WHAT YOU HAVE, BUCK
SEXTON.
>> I JUST SAID THEY WERE
OVERRATED.
>> YOU IT
--
>> I WILL HAVE YOU KNOW.
IT'S THE PROPAGANDA HERE THEY
ARE TELLING YOU YOU HAVE TO LIKE
IT.
WE EVEN CARE WHY THEY BROKE UP
AT THIS POINT?
THEY BROKE UP.
NO ONE CARES.
WHAT WAS THE LAST TIME YOU
LISTEN TO A SONG BY THE BEATLES
ON SPOT FIVE.
DO NOT LIVE.
>> I DID ON VINYL ON SUNDAY.
>> VINYL?
SPEAK OUT YESTERDAY.
>> I AM CHOKING ON THE
PRETENSION RIGHT NOW.
>> IS A PRETENSION OR DO I
ACTUALLY KNOW WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT?
>> SO RINGO DID IT.
>> Greg: IS IN IT THE BIGGER
STORY THAT NO MATTER HOW WELL
YOU GET ALONG IN A BAND, NO
MATTER WHAT YOU END UP HATING
EACH OTHER.
>> YES.
>> TOO MUCH TIME TOGETHER.
>> Greg: IF ONLY THERE WAS A
TV SHOW I COULD REFERENCE.
>> WE WILL NEVER BREAK UP.
>> I AM THE ONLY PERSON WHO
THINKS THERE OVERRATED.
>> I'M A STONES GUY.
LED ZEPPELIN GUY.
JUST THE HAIRDOS, THE BOWL CUT.
SPEWING THEY DID SOME
INTERESTING THINGS.
AND THEY CREATED BASICALLY --
>> THEY CHANGED MUSIC FOREVER
BUT THAT'S NOT ENOUGH FOR BUCK
SEXTON.
>> Greg: WHAT DO YOU LISTEN TO
AND YOUR SHAGGY WAGON?
>> CASSIA
>> YOU ARE NOT SUPPOSED TO TELL
PEOPLE --
>> WHO ARE YOU.
>> COME
>> Greg: YOU THREW HIM UNDER
THE BUS.
>> BUT I THINK WE CAN ALL AND
THE SEGMENT ON ONE THING.
RINGO DI